every corner of the world covered the
mao
and closer to home the dakins from essex
camped out overnight
yeah we were gonna come down first thing
this morning um but then when we saw on
the news yesterday people were already
camping we thought well maybe we should
be camping as well what was it like in
your tent charlie
very cold
over here a mexican wave for a british
monarch what is it about the queen
i think that
um you see i come from a country where
you see presidents coming in and out and
no one laughs you don't remember them
but the queen 70 years on the throne she
she is the really the last great monarch
ever a monarch joseph afrain is proud to
fly the flag for the country is in
crisis
and she speaks
everybody listening to her
that makes it more special
this is mikhail and zion's first royal
event
[Music]
the reason why we've come here today is
because
we would like to celebrate um our
wonderful queen's jubilee
70 years on the throne
the queen has done a lot for us as and
this means a lot
there was of course a lot of dressing up
from balloons to the real thing
who we got here uh we have uh chuckles
and bunting the corgis
the dogs are getting a lot of attention
today yeah 100 well they are very much
on brand
on brand to the flying finale
but even the red arrows can't upstage
the queen
this is what people want to see the
queen on the buckingham palace balcony
she is just a speck in the distance but
that doesn't matter everyone here can
say they've seen her
absolutely amazing just wouldn't miss it
would you it's really emotional actually
and you know something that you've never
seen in your lifetime again or many many
lifetimes you know our children's
lifetimes are brilliant absolutely
brilliant and then there was this
after the polished pageantry and
impromptu moment the jackson family
couldn't believe it
completely overwhelmed truth be told i
wasn't expecting it at all and i feel
very um emotional it's a wonderful day
to be british yeah yeah quite
overwhelming we would have missed it if
we went that way but we just caught it
the briefest of meetings but a day and
memories to last a lifetime laura
bundock sky news on the mao